roll on the [ __ ] I said [ __ ]
welcome back to Miami Florida and I am
pleased to kick off this Thursday
program with a man I've been a big fan
of for quite some time he's a six-time
Emmy Award winner and he will be for the
second straight year the host of NFL
honors 8:00 p.m. Eastern on Fox coming
up this Saturday none other than Steve
Harvey here on the Rich Eisen show great
to see ya good to see you
oh man I'm Velma big friend man you said
you were surprised I came but I've
always loved what you do man thank you
inspired me the 40-yard dash you run
yeah you've made me think about it but
yeah two problems yes I know I normally
blow out both hamstrings but my bigger
problem will be stopping and I think I'm
a fracture eight toes trying to stop and
so it's just it could be just a gradual
slowing of the running no if I run
40-yard dash I need to stop now run the
40 at 42 it's over I can't slow down I'm
done you could do what Deion did when he
ran the 40 at the combine which was run
it and run straight out yeah
oh that was dope into the tunnel yeah I
would die that's too far it's the tunnel
he denies he denies though that he ran
into a waiting limousine to take him to
the airport no he did it's that's that's
what it would sound like by the way you
you are wearing similar shoes to what
Prime did wear when he was here just a
couple days ago this is very nice no
like the crime is wearing something
similar to mine I got it now I taught
all him boys how to dress I was wearing
suits of way back before them guys ever
got into it I'm the teacher of dressing
on television Michael Jordan yes he he
told me to say anything Magic Johnson
that's me I was wearing suits on stage
as a comedian before any other comedian
was doing and so they'd a vault
you steal a copy you saw them draft
pictures you ever seen a motorist
walking up with them big giant suits
that was me that was me Holmes with my
suits yeah Steve Harvey here on the
Richardson show so who'd you meet last
year that you're like okay this is
pretty cool being at the backstage of
honors and all these NFL players that
were Joe Namath right Jim Brown Joe
Brown I was like awesome for me because
I actually like Joe Namath because back
in my neighborhood Joe Namath was the
first black quarterback in the NFL what
I mean by that yeah simply cause he had
a fur coat we adopted him and so he made
just so that was a big moment for me man
yeah but it was like one of the biggest
gigs of my career man because I'm such a
football fan and like I told them I've
never missed the Superbowl I've seen
every single Super Bowl that is my
father started me at seven in 1964
watching the Cleveland Browns played a
Baltimore coach which is the last time
Cleveland has ever won anything anything
and I've been in hopes of one day right
watching a football championship come
but I watch every Super Bowl man yeah I
know you were you were calling out Baker
having a little fun at his expense last
year and he doesn't have a good sense of
humor yeah Baker's not a fun guy he
takes himself way too serious yeah and I
love him man you know when you're a
Cleveland man we like tough boys he's a
tough guy you know but he doesn't have a
good sense of humor he was just looking
at me and I was just looking back at him
and then somebody yelled out Baker's
making more money than you and I said
that's not true
[Laughter]
but Jack Brown I remember when we
started NFL Network and he came in this
was 16 years ago
and he came in and he showed up early he
showed up early and he came out during a
commercial break and we were gonna post
tape after him so he couldn't really be
out there live and we were coming back
and he looked at me he's like how come
I'm not on right now and I was like oh
like I literally had one of those
moments like can somebody please tell
mr. Brown here yeah what is going on
right now because he even now he's 81
years old and it looks like he can still
give you a few snaps right it was you 81
you have to go on now right that's it
now is important than anyone I'm 63 and
now is important like if I have to go to
the bathroom I have to go now
I can't wait tie myself hold it no I
have to go now it's immediate so if you
81
I can't imagine waiting there is no
waiting on anything
no it's nothing wrong okay so one thing
I love about you Steve is when you host
family feud you get it you you realize
that there's a moment that is happening
and you make a meal out of it like you
as a host know we got to stop here and
we have to acknowledge just how insane
this moment just is right now and one of
my favorite ones just like that involves
to fajn digs of the Minnesota Vikings
when he was playing for the fast money
and it was leave it blank he was well
the phrase was leave it blank and he
said in and the whole place went
absolutely nuts and you just stepped
away yeah and just made an absolute
five-course meal out of that cause we
have to drink this moment yeah see sir I
don't see Stefon Diggs look man if you
got your helmet on you your number we
all know who you are once he take the
helmet off we gotta kind of figure who
that
so he didn't have his helmet on I wanted
him to be YouTube famous for the rest of
his life because what's great manatees
you know we do a lot of NFL NBA shows on
family feud for celebrity right it's
great man when regular people discover
that celebrities don't know nothing
don't you think cause a person is famous
they know more they actually know less
they're no less than anybody else
because they're exposed to less rich
people don't know how much milk costs
Richard Richard my son the other day was
dad you don't know what it's like to
take over know if I'm taking over so
people get fired I got a driver
downstairs was and I'm just you get out
of touch man and when they come on
celebrity Family Feud you find out how
out of touch they are they don't know
anything man like one of the questions
for the NFL team was and we were asked
to God running back for the Packers I
can't think of his name but the question
was complete the sentence strip and use
from you know like strip mall strip
strip poker strip Sacketts could be
strip sack yeah I said name complete the
word strip he said per strip her I wish
I could reason how is that your point of
reference to complete the words great
moments and again you just walk away and
you just you realize that in the moment
like okay this is it and I'm gonna let
this thing go after he asked me he said
Steve is there any way we could edit
I said sir we're not getting in and out
matter of fact we're gonna embellish
you're gonna say purr so loud purr
who would that be was that who would be
the Packer don't write back
I can't let me think of as Aaron Jones
was that is it how oh my gosh that we
can't with the dreads a few years ago
could have been am on green or something
like that I don't know it's another
question I have for you about hosting
here Steve Harvey on the Rich Eisen show
so I'm watching New Year's Eve and I'm
watching and I see you have this Lego
bust like a Lego bust of you yeah and
I'm sitting there thinking that is
amazing to have yeah and then out come I
was amazed because they made a Lego of
me right I didn't even know they made
brown Legos
they must be special order I've never
seen a black person in Lego before so I
was amazed I thought it was special I
was pretty impressed it was incredible
and then Gronk comes out in a leather
helmet old school football uniform and
spikes your Lego head breaking it into a
million pieces yeah and I'm thinking
that you genuinely were not pleased to
have that thing to me I was like like
I'm a real honest guy and I just it
something's wrong with him seriously
it's some type of defect I don't know
what it is with him and nicest guy loved
working wonderful yeah but something
Gronkowski is slightly twisted
something's wrong with him man and what
he did it like they told me they said
Steve you're gonna be out there Gronk
has a surprise for you okay okay you
know we on TV his New Year's Eve is live
what can I do all right cool when he
smashed the head I just looked at him
and I was doing a lot of things like you
know why am i working with him
who invited him on the show and I'm
watching it and he did this I just
looked at him man and then he was into
it he's really a mentally imbalanced
person but he's so big what could I do
right you know I don't need I'm not
getting my ass work over a Lego I'm not
gonna take that woman over there I'm
missing that worth so I just played it
off you know I called him a bunch of
names under my breath sure nothing he
could hear right but when it all comes
down to it did you get another Lego did
they note that back together which would
you want another one of those I mean
because I don't I don't know how much to
special-order to brown Legos worse but
I'm not willing to chip in for it right
plus my wife man don't let me put
pictures of myself up in the house she
said if you think you're gonna come into
my house and see pictures of yourself on
this wall mister you're living in
another home I can't put pictures of
myself up in the house and I'm an avid
cigar guy okay
and I cannot smoke I bought all those
houses so there's my pain all of those
houses she don't let me smoke in my damn
house there's no Steve Harvey man cave
yeah I have a man cave I finally got
that okay you got that I had to beg for
that cause my little Richards kids
wanted a bowling alley and you know I'm
so sick of them kids man see they didn't
grow up like they father you know how
you always want your children to have a
better life than what you had sure so
I've given them that and I've regretted
it every six because they've never done
anything to earn this life they have
right they wanted a bowling alley in the
house how do you come and say that Bob
it's like my daughter she's an
equestrian rider okay she came to me and
asked for a horse
I bought my daughter a horse I asked my
daddy for a pony when I was eight years
old
how'd that go he told me you better go
outside and put some hair on that bite
[Music]
that's the difference in the life that
we had sure but did you give them did
you build a bowling alley they did it
yeah okay and then they all my kids are
grown now my youngest is 22 right so
they moved out so I told a bowling alley
out and I put a golf simulator down and
I bought in a very expensive smoke
system and so now I can smoke cigars at
my golf simulator with a humidor walk in
I'm so pimped out now but I had to wait
till all my kids moved out my son came
home and said dad what happened to my
room I said that's not your room anymore
that's the cigar lounge and so they all
have no nothing left how is your golf
game oh I'm not good man I'm like a 16
handicap but I am the greatest every now
Indian golfer on planet Earth
okay cuz i only play every now and then
and i play really well sometimes that's
a lot of times i hit the ball and i have
no idea why the ball went that way i
just hit it and it went somewhere i buy
a lot of balls cuz i don't go in the
woods looking for ball you know a guy
told me you get a penalty stroke I don't
give a damn I'm not hunting for this
ball and then you see rattlesnakes yeah
you're not picking up Lyme disease for a
small I'm looking for lots of balls that
cost $35
I got a 180 balls in my bag you can't
even lift my banjo
[Laughter]
before a lull playing man before I let
before I let you go to get a prediction
for Sunday who do you think's when it's
you're both in Cleveland I really don't
care who wins but I'm leaning towards
Kansas City okay because of Patrick
Mahone but I'm scared of the Frisco
defense yep and I just think Richard
Sherman's a bad boy I think they're
gonna be back there I think they have
one of the greatest defenses in a long
time but I don't know how you stop that
offense for four quarters I think
they're gonna sneak sneak a couple of a
man so if I was a betting man I'd have
to go with Kansas City but I'm from
Cleveland and you learn not to bet yeah
it's just nothing but sort this is
painful
it's very painful well I appreciate you
coming on this show Steve and I can't
wait to see you at the mic again you
were awesome as a host all I can tell
you is Saturday night the monologue that
I'm writing for Saturday night yes Wow I
won't be back next year I will not make
a third season but my Marty laws ought
to be pretty good so you're getting
canceled after a blaze of glory so check
it all out on Fox 8:00 Eastern and
Pacific on Saturday night the NFL honors
at I am Steve Harvey on Twitter and uh I
am Steve Harvey on TV as I said huge fan
sir thank you for that we got Steve
Harvey here on the Rich Eisen show
everybody for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 under
red TV for free on BR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app